you know what's interesting about the
internet and like internet people
is that i've noticed that a lot of them
seem to be really lonely
and this is coming from an internet
person right like i'm on the internet i
do social media
i've noticed that
the lonelier i am and the less
friends i have
in close relationships the better i do
on the internet because it's almost like
you have more to give to the internet
and i noticed it because i noticed like
that
a lot of the content creators that i
follow and the people that i watch were
alone on christmas
and
there wouldn't ever be a shot in hell
that i would be alone on christmas um
i'm always gonna have i'm lucky i have a
really big family right
so i'm always gonna have somewhere to go
but i was thinking about how sad that is
and
it just seems like the lonely like
character almost
seems to do well on the internet i guess
i don't know this is just a thought i
had on my way to the gym so
that's it that's that's the video
don't forget to subscribe bye guys